what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and we have some
crazy
awesome news today about keanu reeves
finally joining a marvel property
however
it may not be the marvel cinematic
universe but he could actually cross
over with
tom holland spider-man venom morbius and
possibly the sinister
six fans have been wanting keanu reeves
in a marvel role for some time he's the
number one voted person to play
wolverine
and probably the number one person voted
to play ghost
rider but it looks like he may be coming
to the sony pictures
universe of marvel characters or the sp
umc
in the form of craven the hunter and
i'll dive into this report but if you're
new and you love marvel be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest marvel news
now this report is coming from the
illuminerde.com and they have a pretty
good track record when it comes to
breaking exclusive news
one of their most recent reports was the
announcement that christian bale was
going to be in thor love and thunder and
of course during disney's investors day
the president of marvel studios kevin
feige did announce that christian bale
is going to be playing gore the god
butcher so very good track record indeed
from the illuminati and they are saying
that the role of craven the hunter is
keanu reeves's
if he wants it they have not said that
he has accepted the role yet
on their website they said that they
received word that sony gave an official
offer to hollywood megastar kiana reeves
to star as craven hunter in his
own solo film they say that the project
is being referred to simply as
craven at this time according to their
source they were also given a
description of the tone that the studio
was looking for and they described the
tone of the movie as a mashup of
man on fire and logan so for those of us
who wanted him to play wolverine we
might get sort of a wolverine style
movie if he accepts craven the hunter
but what the illuminati said is that
there's no final decision yet simply the
offer has been extended
to him to play the role of craven the
hunter in his own solo film he has not
accepted it yet now a lot of us weren't
really expecting keanu reeves to play
craven the hunter and i know a lot of
people are wanting him to appear in the
actual mcu not in the sony universe that
they've created over there but there are
some benefits to him
being craven the hunter and one is that
he could appear with tom holland
spider-man one day
as we've noticed over the past year year
and a half now sony and marvel have
apparently worked out a deal that some
characters from the sony universe can
cross over into the mcu
as long as those characters only appear
in spider-man films so there is a
possibility that he could
technically be a part of the mcu if they
decide to use him in that way
there is also a possibility that if he
does accept the role of craven the
hunter he could eventually go on to
appear in the sinister six and go to
take on tom hall and spider-man
and this would be really cool because he
would appear alongside of tom hardy's
venom
jared leto's morbius jake gyllenhaal's
mysterio if he returns in spider-man 3
michael keaton's vulture and many more
awesome characters
as far as the actual role of craven the
hunter goes keanu reeves is a really
good fit for the character
a bounty hunter who was really good at
hunting people down and killing them and
if you don't think he's right for the
role just go ahead and watch the first
john wick keanu does an
excellent job of playing a character
that hunts somebody down and kills
a lot of people in between so not a bad
casting choice however
i'm not sure keanu reeves will actually
accept this role and here's the reason
why
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has already admitted that they
talked to keanu reeves pretty much about
every single movie that they do
they talked to him to see if he could be
right for a role in a movie whether
that's a hero or a villain
they talk to him to see if they can find
a good role that's perfect now they
haven't found one yet
obviously he's not in the mcu yet but
this is exactly the same thing that
happened with jake gyllenhaal and
mysterio
marvel studios revealed that they met
with jake gyllenhaal years in advance
before finally landing on mysterio they
were just waiting for the perfect role
for him until they finally landed upon
mysterio that's exactly what they're
doing with keanu reeves but if he
accepted the deal with sony to play
craven
he probably couldn't play a character in
the mcu after that because it would just
be too confusing
it wouldn't really make sense for him to
go play craven and then for him to go
play ghost rider or wolverine and marvel
studios
probably wouldn't like that after all
marvel studios didn't want
tom holland to interact with venom in
the first venom movie because they
thought fans would be confused and think
their universes were the same and they
didn't want that so they probably
wouldn't want one of their actors
playing two different roles one in the
mcu and another in the sp umc
so i think if you're kiana reeves and
you've been talking to marvel studios
for years you probably
would pass on sony but at the same time
who knows keanu may think he is perfect
for the role of craven hunter and may
accept the role but let me know what you
all think about this
do you think keon reeves is a good fit
to play craven the hunter would you like
to see him in this role or would you
rather him play a different character
in the marvel cinematic universe let me
know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you